one of the things that we do here at the
news
is talk about entrepreneurs and
inspiring people who are doing things
out there in the world
our next guest is a beauty brand founder
who launched the first ever natural hair
care vending machines
in the u.s she runs diva by cindy hair
care line
that gives back please welcome cindy
tawiah
hi cindy
hi true hi ross oh my god
you're cute i just got to tell you i
just have to thank
you your products
are in sally's beauty supplies and
walmart.com
um and so are we at flower beauty so i'm
very happy to be
sisters in business with you and oh
thank you drew i've looked into getting
a vending machine and it is no easy
feat oh my goodness trey well i had a
wonderful successful thriving blooming
store
at bwi airport and i put that story
there because tsa takes away
all our hair care products and it's so
traumatic i know you've been through it
i know you've been through it you go
through they look at the elves and
they're they're like you can't take this
through
yeah yeah yes so i opened the store
everything was going great and then one
day they took away my store
it was like you know we're reclaiming
the space
and i was devastated i had to lay
everybody off
and literally close my store and you
know what
a girl's got to get on her feet after a
few months i went right back to that
airport
met with the ceo mr ricky put my
powerpoint presentation in his face and
i said
this is what i want to bring here and he
looked at me he said young lady
you're very persistent how many airports
do you want how many concourses you want
i said that's
it amen we're in so that's how that
[Applause]
you got to figure out how to bring it
back yeah you got to pivot right if you
want to be successful and i know your
business
it is successful and and a core part of
it is
not only providing products for women
but taking care of women
as well why is that important to you oh
my god ross
i'm a survivor of domestic violence but
one of the things that's very very
important is
we donate 10 of our proceeds to homeless
shelters
and then we do beauty makeovers it's
called the diva project
where we go out and we give them a full
beauty makeover and it's so important
for us
to give back to our community and
especially women who are hurting and
broken
i mean right i mean i'm
i i love you i love you
i just have so much admiration for you i
don't know where to begin
thank you so much and i iu because
sisters have to take care of sisters
women have to pour
into each other instead of tearing each
other down
we have to build each other up that's
how we rise well you're such a caretaker
i mean you weren't always in the beauty
industry right you were a nurse for 13
years
yes i was a nurse for 13 years and what
led me to this point was um you know i
had a chemistry teacher
who taught me how to make nail polish
and lipstick
when i was 16 years old in ghana west
africa
this teacher mr o'fair he saw that i was
struggling and instead of giving me
another
f which i had been getting by the way he
said young lady i'm gonna teach you how
to make nail polish and lipstick and
you're going to learn to love my class
and then when he was done he had me be
part of the science fair that was for
the bright intelligent students
not for dodos like me so of course at
the science fair he presented me as a
cosmetologist and a chemist and i
thought oh
god that's what i want to be when i grow
up i went home told my daddy he said no
you are going into the medical field i
didn't send you
to school so that you could go and do
the beauty thing
and i thought wow so fear shot me down i
stayed in nursing
and 13 years later i got my wings i got
my
courage and i left i left nursing to
pursue my passion and my purpose
and that's why i'm here today i had to
change my focus to change my future
wow actually
mr okay um has a message for you
um go ahead and roll the clip please i
see me
i'm very proud of you and all your
accomplishments
i do hope that you continue to be an
inspiration
for all young girls around the world
[Music]
and continue to inspire them to achieve
their goals
congratulations
[Applause]
i'm sorry oh my god
he saved my life and the lives of so
many other women
oh my god thank you true he saved my
life
and because of him so many women have
been touched
because of one person having
faith in another i'm sorry oh my god
don't be sorry i feel like such a lucky
fly on the wall of this moment that you
so deserve oh my god oh my
cindy i just can't wait to see what you
do next
and please let's stay friends and in
touch and
continue to shine a light on you know
everything that you're doing because i
just think the world of you and your you
can check out her products online
at diva by cindy.com and thank you for
being on the show
thanks so much
connect with you and help you with your
vending machine i'm here for you
yeah i need your guidance because i i
totally couldn't pull it off
thank you so much i think you have a lot
to teach cindy
thank you ross thank you
[Music]